الشتاء والمخيمات السوريه عودو على بدل
لسانحارب ناشطين على منصات التواصل الذين
انتقدوا عدم ايجاد حل جذري لمعاناه
النازحين السوريين
واصله مطالب بتقديم مساعدات عاجله
للنازحين الذين يعانون من ضيق الحال اصلا
وفي مقطع المصور
النشط مصطفى ابو عرب حدثت الطفل عطاء عن
صعوبه العيش واضطرارها لتجميع النايلون
والاوراق لاشعال المدفئه للاحتمال
العيشه صعبه نقعد الصبح بدنا نشغل الصوبه
ما عنا نروح نلاقي من على الطريق النايلون
ونشغله الصوبه ومعنا لعبه ريم وراحت نقعد
الصبح ما بتجيب لنا كعكه
اللي احنا واخوتنا ما به شيء لموت نفطر مع
ابو شيكل هاي الروح نشغل النار
ما يعطيني شيء
فصول السنه يكون فيها اللاجئين السوريون
يكون لهم فيها معاناه قديمه متجدده
باستمرار فما بين برد الشتاء وحر الصيف
ينتقل قاتل المخيمات من معاناه الى معاناه
حيث لا سقفه ولا حيطان برده شتاء وحر
الصيف غير قطعه قماش ممزقه واسمها خيمه
ارض ايضا محمود
حلايقه يقول في ازمه اللاجئين حكايات
الصبر والفقر والجوع والبرد يجتمعون لا
نراها الا على عيون اطفالها
اطفال وكبار
السلطع
ام فئه الجميع
راغب ابو شامه كتب هو الاخر يقول مخيمات
الشمال السوري هؤلاء سيخبرون الله بكل شيء
ويا ويلي يا ويله كل من بيده فعل شيء وقصر
وكل من رضي واعان وبرر لاي نظام كان جهز
جوابك بين يديه
الامطار الغزيره
تشكلت ما ادى الى اغلاق طرق ودخول المياه
الى الخيام
فذكرت ان سبعه مخيمات على الاقل تضررت
جرات تساقط الامطار في المنطقه
انا من عمان زايد غيث الناشطه في العمل
التطوعي ونائب رئيس الاتحاد العالمي
للجمعيات الخيريه يعني هذه ماساه متكرره
منذ سنين لكن البرد هذا العام الشديد في
كل انحاء العالم هل هل الاستجابه لماسات
اللاجئين السوريين في شمال السوري
قلت ام ان الظروف هي التي ساعدت
بسم الله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
للاسف يعني في كل عام تتجدد هذه المسائل
انسانيه الحقيقيه لاخواننا اللاجئين
السوريين في الشمال السوري او داخل
المخيمات اللجوء في اغلب الدول العربيه
الذين لجاوا فيها هذه الماساه المتجدده
عند اللاجئين السوريين للاسف المجتمع
الدولي يتحمل المسؤوليه العظمى بهذا الامر
لانه المجتمع الدولي على سبيل المثال انا
باذكر مثلا بالاردن طلب بالاردن المفوضيه
الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين 46 مليون دولار من
اجل تقديم العون والمساعده للاجئين
السوريين من الناحيه ايه وسائل التدفئه لم
تستطيع المفوضيه الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين
ان تحصل على هذا التمويل بنفس الوقت هناك
انفاق بشكل كبير جدا على الازمه
الاوكرانيه على سبيل المثال خلال عشر او
خلال الست شهور الاولى من الازمه
الالكترونيه تم انفاق اكثر من 17 مليار
دولار على استضافه اللاجئين الاوكران دول
اوروبا المجتمع الدولي مقصر بشكل كبير جدا
في تقديم يد العون والمساعده للاجئين
واحنا بنشوف مشاهد ماساويه للكثير من
الاخوه والاخوات والارامل وكبار السن
والعجزه في هذا الوقت في هذا البرد القارس
في هذا البرد الذي لا يستطيع الكثير من
الموجودين داخل المنازل ان يتحملوا هذا
البرد ولذلك التحمل الرئيسي والمشر
الرئيسيه بالمجتمع الدولي الذي بدا لا
يلتفت الى سوريا بشكل واضح والان داخل
السوري الى الخارج السوري الى اللاجئين
بشكل عام اصبح الان اللاجئ السوري وللاسف
الشديد انا بقول بمنتهى تجرد اصبح مهمش
واصبحت هناك ازدواجيه في المعايير الدوليه
في التعاون مع اللاجئين في اغلب الدول
التي سواء الاردن او لبنان او تركيا
المجتمع الدول الان تخلى عن واجبه الانسان
في تقديم العون والمساعده للاجئين سواء
بالداخل او بالخارج بالداخل سوريا هناك
اكثر من خمسه مليون
ناجح سوري داخل المخيمات هو بالشمال
السوري او غيرها هذه المخيمات لا تقي ابدا
من البرد لانه اي خيام بهذه الشكليه وبهذه
الوضعيه المياه تغمرها الاوضاع الانسانيه
تكون بشكل ماساوي جدا يستطيع الانسان
يتحمل ال- ال- الحر ولكن لا يستطيع ان
يتحمل هذا البرد بشكل واضح
هناك اصوات وهناك محاولات لاحياء هذه
الملف وتصفيه الضوء على هذه المعاناه كما
شاهدنا الان مثلا اعلى من ست التواصل
الاجتماعي هل تعتقد ان هذه الحملات وهذه
الجهود تؤتي اكلها في تغيير المشهد في لفت
الانظار نحو هذه المعنى
يعني يعني هو هذه المحاولات او هذه
المباراه الفرديه ماجورين من يقومون عليها
وهي محاوله بشكل غير مباشر من اجل تسليط
الضوء على هذه المعاناه الانسانيه ولكن
انا باكد انه اغلب هذه المبادرات
مجتمعه لا تستطيع ان تفي ب 10% من اجمالي
المعاناه الانسانيه لاخواننا السوريين هم
يستطيع ان يركزوا او او يصلوا الضوء على
هذه المعاناه من اجل انه المجتمع الدولي
او من اجل انه المنظمات العربيه
والاسلاميه اللي الان انا بتكلم بكل تجارب
بكل صراحه انه اغلب المنظمات العربيه
والاسلاميه اللي كانت تقدم المستندات
اصبحت الان تتراجع بشكل واضح وكبير هذه
المعاناه الانسانيه بحاجه الى مبادرات
فرديه من اجل تسليط الضوء عليها ولكن
الاصل ان هناك منظمات دوليه وهناك دول ال
تستطيع ان تقوم بهذه الواجب الانساني لانه
هذه المشكله كبيره جدا ليست مشكله مبادرات
مباراه تستطيع ان تحل بعض المشاكل اما
المشكله الكبيره المتجدده الدكتور زايد
ذكرت المجتمع الدولي انا اشكرك هذه مشكله
عربيه في بلد عربي محاطه سوريا ومحاطه من
كل جهاتها بدول العربيه او اسلاميه
الطبيعي ان هذه الدول
فاينها اين الدور الدول الدول
العربيه في ماساه اللاجئين والنازحين
السوريين طيب انا انا بشكرك جدا على
السؤال واسمح لي اني اكون صريح زياده عن
اللزوم في الاجابه لانه مطلعه بشكل دقيق
وحثيث الدول العربيه والاسلاميه بقولها
وانا مسؤول عن كلامي تخلت عن ملف الاغاثه
اللاجئين السوريين
والدول العربيه والاسلاميه للاسف انا
بقولها بمنتهى الصدق ومن منتهى الالم
الداخلي لهذه المعاناه تمنع تمنع تحويل
مبالغ للداخل السوري من اجل اغاثه تمنع
وانا مسؤول عن كلمتي حتى
عمليه البسطاء انه ممكن تكون في منظمات
عربيه بسيطه انها توصت هذه المساعدات
تمنعها الدول العربيه يا سيدي باختصار
تقول لاخواننا اللاجئين داخل سوريا اذهب
انت وربك فقط قاتله للاسف الشديد تخلوا
عنهم بامس الحاجه هم الان لها انا متابعه
وانا ببعث لاغلب الدول العربيه والاسلام
مفيش غير الكثير من الدول يستجيب على
استحياء على استحياء من اجل تقديم
المساعدات اما عندما نتحل نتكلم عن
التكافل والتضامن كما قال النبي عليه
الصلاه والسلام مثل المؤمنين في توادهم
وتراحمهم وتعاطفهم كمثل الجسد الواحد اذا
اشتكى منها عضوا تدعى له سعر الجسدي
بالسهر والحمى انا باقول انه هذا الحديث
العظيم النبي للاسف اخواننا العرب
والمسلمين تخلوا عن وجوههم الانسان يعني
لا اطالبهم بشيء اخر انا بطالبهم بواجب
انساني ليس له علاقه باي شيء سياسي او او
امني او اشي اخر انا بطالبهم انه يستطيعوا
يستطيع لا يظن احد انه لا يستطيع الدول
العربيه التي تتواصل مع الحكومه السوريه
تتواصل مع المفوضيه تتواصل مع العاملين
تتواصل مع المنظمات العامل داخل السوري
تتواصل مع الجهات النشطه داخل سوري او
شمال سوريا ولكن انا باتكلم بكل تجربه
واخرى على رعايته الاخرانيين فليتاسو به
ليس كذلك
يعني يعني انت ذكرت نقطه جوهريه انا تحدثت
في بدايه حديث وقلت في مؤتمر قبل مده في
احد الدول الاوروبيه وحقيقه شيء يدمى له
القلب عندما ترى هذا التكافل وهذا التضامن
من الدول العربيه من دول الغربيه
والاوروبيه بمساعده اللاجئين الاوكران كيف
بيستقبلوهم انا شوف ذلك ما حدا حكى لي كنت
موجود بنفس الدوله اللي كانت تستقبل وبشوف
هذا التخلي وهذا عفوا على هذا التعبير
الاسلاميه الخير